sie haben in den vergangenen Tagen ja
sozusagen die Aufgabe gehabt die Toten
dort nach diesen schrecklichen
Kriegsverbrechen von der Straße zu holen
Fotos zu machen das alles zu
dokumentieren sie haben auch die Zahl
der Leichen dort gezählt wir sehen
einige ihrer Aufnahmen die sie dort
gemacht haben Herr minschenko das sind
Bilder die uns schon nicht aus dem Kopf
gehen warum haben Sie das gemacht warum
haben Sie das gemacht
[Musik]
ich wurde gebeten von unseren Soldaten
die ist zu dokumentieren wenigstens zu
fotografieren nur deshalb
ich brauche diese Fotos nicht bei mir im
Telefon und ich hoffe wenn alles zu Ende
ist werde ich diese Fotos auch bei mir
löschen können es ist einfach die
Dokumentation der Verbrechen des
Russlands wir haben diese Bilder auch
noch mal gezeigt und sie sagen sie
brauchen diese Bilder nicht aber selbst
wenn die vom Handy gelöscht sind die
bleiben uns ja schon in den Köpfen die
wir viele viele Kilometer entfernt sind
und diese Bilder nur immer wieder auch
unseren Zuschauern zeigen um zu zeigen
was für schreckliche Kriegsverbrechen
begangen wurden auch bei ihnen eben in
Butcher vor allen Dingen aber was machen
sie mit all diesen Bildern selbst wenn
sie sie irgendwann löschen werden von
Ihrem Telefon die bleiben doch im Kopf
[Musik]
ich hoffe sehr dass ich das vielleicht
irgendwie vergessen kann
ich möchte diese Bilder nicht bei mir in
Erinnerung behalten dass es schrecklich
es ist ein Schrecken es sind Menschen
die erschossen sind die verbunden sind
verbrannt und
anderen Menschen sind einfach
Essensreste vielleicht haben die
Menschen gerade zu Abend gegessen und
wurden dabei ermordet
wir sind Menschen die
war einfach sie bewegt haben auf dem
Fahrrad jemand hat Kartoffeln mit sich
geführt jemand Holz alle erschossen
ich versuche mich gerade zu sammeln das
ist ein Schrecken
wir haben Hunde und Beine zwei Tage
gesammelt
[Musik]
sie stehen genau dort wo man versucht
den Toten nach diesem schrecklichen
Kriegsverbrechen noch ja ein bisschen
würde wieder zurückzugeben wir haben
diese Bilder gesehen in den Leichen
Säcken wie sie dort einfach reingeworfen
worden gestapelt wurden in diesen langen
Gräben Massengräber dort auf dem
Friedhof vielleicht können Sie uns das
einmal zeigen verbunden mit der Frage
hier aus Berlin angesichts dessen was
geschehen ist glauben sie an Gott an so
etwas wie Gott
glaube ich noch mehr an Gott denn nur
Gott hat mich davor bewahrt was ich
gerade erlebt habe ich wurde beinahe
erschossen ich bin unter bombenhagen
geraten und es ist der Gott der
vielleicht hat er mich davor bewahrt
weil ich jetzt hier gebraucht werde
dafür was ich gerade tue
ich habe es nicht geplant ich wollte es
nicht tun aber so ist es gekommen großer
waffenlieferer ist Estland mit dem
Gegenwert von 200 Millionen Euro
ungefähr an Waffenlieferung gleichzeitig
zahlt die EU sie sehen es hier unten im
Bild auf dem geldzähler fast 30
Milliarden seit Kriegsbeginn an Putin
für Gas und für Öl also das ist ja auch
eine wahnsinnige Unwucht wir schmücken
uns mit gewaltigen Waffenlieferung von
paar Millionen von paar Millionen Euro
und gleichzeitig fließt dieser Betrag
und immer immer mehr während dieser
Sendung an Putin für Gas und Öl plagt
sie in schlechtes Gewissen gegenüber der
Ukraine gegenüber Herrn minschenko ein
schlechtes Gewissen müssen die haben die
den Krieg führen Deutschland führt den
Krieg nicht wir versuchen die Ukraine zu
unterstützen so gut wir können und
dieses können ist natürlich immer auch
eine Frage der Einschätzung die man dazu
hat ich sage nochmal Sanktionen dienen
dem Zweck die andere Seite zu bestrafen
und das ist so schnell wie möglich raus
müssen aus dem Gast das ist unstrittig
das werden wir auch tun die Frage wie
schnell das geht da gehen die Meinung
auseinander und was die Waffenlieferung
angeht da gehen die Meinung auch
auseinander abgesehen davon dass es mir
Waffenlieferungen gibt als öffentlich
bekannt ist will ich ausdrücklich noch
mal sagen und das was teilweise zwischen
der ukrainischen Regierung und der
deutschen Regierung in den Telefonaten
von Olaf Scholz mit henselenski
besprochen wird unterscheidet sich
durchaus von dem was öffentlich also sie
haben gesagt ein reines Gewissen sie
sagen nicht wir hätten noch das war die
entscheidende Frage der Fuchs gerade
gestellt hat sollten wir mehr tun und
sie können Herrn minschenko ins Gesicht
sagen wir tun genug wir tun alles was
wir können Herrn minschenko die können
das polemisch so formulieren ich sage
doch das sind eine polemische Form
mehrere frage ich sage nicht wir tun das
was wir nach meiner Einschätzung nach
besten Kräften tun können das müssen wir
auch tun weil wir natürlich auf der
Seite der Ukraine stehen und der
Aggressor Putin zurückgewiesen werden
muss das ist ja gar keine Frage das sind
Angriffskriege hier wenn
Kriegsverbrechen begangen und Putin muss
gestoppt werden da ist der Distanz nicht
der dezent ist in der Frage wie schnell
das geht und dann sagen die einen die
sind die anderen jenes am Ende müssen
Politiker das entscheiden und sich der
verreckt werden in jedem Land übrigens
ich erinnere noch mal daran die
Sanktionen werden übrigens auch
gemeinsam beschlossen mit unserer
Verbündeten das ist keine alleinige
Entscheidung der deutschen was da
geschieht sondern gibt es total eng
übrigens der Verbündeten eine treibende
Kraft innerhalb der EU hermenschenko
noch mal zu Ihnen nach Botschaft dort
auf diesen Friedhof von Butcher ihr
Präsident selenski
er hat in den vergangenen Stunden gesagt
der findet die Deutschen in diesem Fall
kühl empfinden sie diese Debatte die wir
jetzt auch hier im Studio wieder führen
mit unseren Gästen aus der Politik aus
Deutschland auch ihnen gegenüber als
kühl
ja das finde ich auch unser Gespräch ist
kühl und es geht um nichts solange ihr
spricht und etwas ausdiskutiert Menschen
sterben in botja in rostommel in
paradian kam und anderen Städten wird
geschossen in mir geräute wurde
geschossen und wir sprechen nicht wir
sondern ihr spricht es ist erreicht
einfach unterbricht alle Beziehungen mit
Russland gibt und zwar von kein Öl kein
Gas aus Russland ihr spricht ich weiß
nicht Jungs in welcher Welt lebt ihr ihr
lebt vielleicht in einen anderen Galaxie
Menschen
sterben und wir sprechen
Entschuldigung nein sie brauchen sich
nicht entschuldigen Herr menschenke euch
danke Ihnen herzlich dass Sie mit uns
gesprochen haben an diesem Sonntag